حياكم الله طلب القوه تحب السلام الموجوده
في لبنان يونيفيل من السلطات اللبنانيه
الاسراع في اتمام التحقيقات ومحاسبه
المسؤولين عن اطلاق النار على مدرعه سنه
مرورها في منطقه العقديه خارجه منطقه
عمليات القوه الدوليه في جنوب لبنان
الهجوم ما الذي يسفر عن مقتل جندي ايرلندي
واصابه ثلاثه اخرين بجروح تاتي هذه
الحادثه لتنضم الى سلسله الميدانيه بين
القوات الدوليه والاهالي تفلت بين المناطق
اللبنانيه اللبنانيه عدى في الجنوب
ميليشيا حزب الله بالوقوف خلفها بطريقتين
مباشره من خلال استخدامه للاهالي
والاختباء خلفهم لتحقيق اهداف سياسيه
وايصال رسائل الى قوه حفظ السلام ومن ثم
الى
المجتمع الدولي
راديكي شان
ان تكون سلطه الدوله سواء بالتحقيقات او
سواء بالامن مبسوطه على كل اراضيها
[موسيقى]
لقد حان الوقت بالحان من زمان لان تضع
الدوله يدها على كل سلاح متفلتين وغير
شرعيه
ينضم الينا من بيروت
القياديه في حزب القوات اللبنانيه
ومن بيروتي ايضا ينضم الينا مالك ابي نادر
الكاتب الصحفي اهلا بكما يعني
ابدا اولا مع جده
كيف تنظرون الى هذا الحادث هل هو حادث
عربي ام فعل متعمد
في لبنان السياده
داخل الدوله وقد اثرت هذه الدول في قطب
كافه مؤسسات الدوله اللبنانيه ثم اوصانا
الى الحاله المساويه التي نراها اليوم هذا
الحادث لا يمكن فصله عن العديد من الحوادث
وهنا لابد من استذكار مره شديد
الرائد الشهيد سامحنا الذي قتل من قبل
العناصر حزب الله همم
20 سنوات وذلك لانه كان يقود طائره تعود
الجيش اللبناني
مره جديد
كان هناك همم يقوم بها حزب الله تحت ستار
الاهالي من اجل ايصال رسائل ان كانت
داخليه او خارجيه وهذا يؤكد بان على
الدوله اللبنانيه بالتبسط سلطتها على كافه
الاراضي وهذا يح على كافه المسؤوليه
السياسيين وعلى النواب وعلى كافه حارسين
على هذا البلد الذهاب نحو بناء دوله
حقيقيه فعاليه والا سوف نبقى ندفع ثمن
المزرعه التي نعيشها حاليا
السيد مالك بن نادر الكاتب الصحفي سيد
مالك يعني حادث عربي الاهالي ام هو فعل
متعمد وقد يكون هناك وراء من يريد ايصال
رساله كما قال السيد جاد
مساء الخير مساء النور
وكان الجميع مؤسسات الدوله تعمل كما يجب
وكان الجيش اللبناني يستطيع ان يفسد سلطته
على كامل الاراضي اللبنانيه عندها لن يكون
همم بحاجه الى قوه الدوليه في الجنوب
لبنان يحمي حدوده ولكن الاستهداف الدولي
للدوله اللبنانيه ومنعها من الاستحواذ على
مقدرات القوه ومقدرات المنعه الذاتيه
للاسف ترك مجال للاطراف لبعض الاطراف التي
همم
تلقت تلقت نتيجه ذلك نتيجه هذا الضعف في
اجهزه الدوله يومها قديما انطلقت همم
الانتقالات الاسرائيليه وغيرها نحن لا
نتكلم عن الموضوع نعم همم همم ما حصل ما
حصل لم يكن يجب ان يحصل كما كما هو ولكن
يجب ان نتذكر ان الجنوب عامه منذ ومنذ
عشرات السنين هو مركز هو موقع لبناني
يتعرض دائما وفيه البيئات تعيش حذرا تعيش
تعيش همم احداث تعيش تعيش همم الخوف من
الاجتاح الاسرائيلي الخوفي دخول منشات
اخرى لتذهب الى الحدود لتذهب الى الحدود
وتمارس مقاومه بشكل بشكل غير منسق مع
الدوله اللبنانيه وكلنا نكون نتذكر قديما
كيف كانت [__] الصواريخ الصواريخ
الكاتيوشا على على اسرائيل لاستفزاز العدو
الاسرائيلي لجلبه الى الاعتداء على
الاراضي اللبنانيه يعني
زوم
ايه بس بس بس هذا الواقع من خلق هذا
الواقع الانفلات الامني والسلاح
همم اشخاص غير الدوله ام ام هو واقع يعني
مفروض عليهم باعتبار انه لا سلاح الا سلاح
من الاشياء حزب الله في الجنوب
يا سيدي اولا اعتقد ان الدوله مقصره
باندست ان تمتلك القدرات الكافيه لحمايه
لحمايه الجنوب وكلنا نعلم انه حتى قبل
وجود حزب الله الجنوب تعرض لاربعه او خمس
اجتياحات
واعتداءات قبل ان قبل ان قبل ان قبل ان
يتشكل حزب الله انا لا انا لا اقول انا لا
ادافع عن احد انا انا اوصف حاله تاريخيه
انا اوصف حاله تاريخيه وكلنا على ان الحزب
الله وجد بعد الاجتاح الاسرائيلي الذي وصل
الى بيروت هل هذا صحيح ام لا وبعد اعتداء
78 الذي رسم منطقه امنيه عمقه 40 كم واوجد
واوجد واقعا سيئا في الجنوب الدوله مطلوب
منها لا ان تقول اريد ان يكون لدي خليني
اسمع سيد جدا القيادي في حزب القوات
اللبنانيه الدوله هي المسؤوله وفقا كلام
السيد مالك لا يريد ان يدافع عن احد ولكن
الدوله ليس بيدها همم حيله ليس بيدها شيء
بينما حزب الله السلاح
المتمثله في السنوات السابقه بحزب الله
والتيار الوطني الحر وحلفائهما وبالتالي
لسوء الحظ لم يعد هنالك فقط دويلا ودوله
في لبنان بل اصبحت الدوله
التي هي حزب الله وحلفاءه وبالتالي هذه
العمليه في رمي الاتهامات بين تحميل
مسؤوليه للدوله او للدول نحن وصلنا الى
هذه الحاله لانه هنالك من ما زال من من ما
زال يبدي مصلحه الدول على مصلحه الدوله
حزب الله بادائيه
وبتصرفاته وفي قدمه مؤسسات الدوله وفي همم
عدم اعطاء اي مساحه
لسلطات الدوله الحقيقيه والشرعيه والفعليه
لتحكم بطريقه مؤسستيه قد اوصل الامور الى
الحاله التي وصلنا اليها اليوم التحالف
بين الم اقوال ميليشيا قد ادى الى تدهور
مستمر في سياده الدوله اللبنانيه والى
ايصال الامور الى ما وصلنا اليه اليوم لا
يمكن عدم تحميل حزب الله هذه المساله هذه
المسؤوليه
اللي اللي ربما بيدهم السلاح لماذا حزب
الله
عليها في الايام الاخيره تؤكد بان هنالك
مسؤوليه وبان العمل كان اكثر من مجرد عمل
عفوي نحن نعلم جيدا بانه ليس ذلك اي شئ
يحصل في الجنوب اللبناني من دون علم حزب
الله واكثر من ذلك لسوء الحظ كافه الامور
التي تكون مرتبطه بحزب الله تكون نتائج
التحقيقات فيها لا شيء وهذا سوف يحصل
اليوم او ما ما ما ما نراه حتى هذه اللحظه
في التحقيقات التي تطال هذه الحادثه
حزب الله الى المجتمع الدولي وحتى الداخل
في ظل هذه الاسواره همم
المنبه وفي ظل ان كفاء اغلبيه الدول
واعتقد بان لبنان اليوم هو ليس من ضمن
اولويات المجتمع الدولي يحاول ولا بان
يعيد ترتيب الامور وان يقول للجميع بان
الامر في لبنان هو لي وان كان لابد من
حوار او من تحاور او من تسويه لا بد ان
اكون بصلها وكما انا همم بامكاني ان اكون
جزء من الحل بامكانها ان اكون جزء من
الفوضى وهذه رساله صغيره كي يؤكد بان هو
جاهز على الاقدام على اي فوضى ممكن ان
تحدث في الفتره
الكاتب الصحفي من بيروت هل توافق على انه
بالفعل حسبي الله قد يريد ايصال هذه هكذا
رسائل ام ان وايضا انه كما قال السيد جاد
بانه التحقيقات قد لا تصل الى شيء
سيدي اعتقد ان الدوله اللبنانيه للاجهزه
الامنيه اللبنانيه هي تقوم بتحقيق جده
وقياده اليونيفيل تقول ان التحقيقات التي
تجيها الاجهزه الامنيه اللبنانيه كافيه
ونحن سنتعاون معها والجميع ينتظر حتى
الدوله الهولنديه التي خسرت احد جنودها
احد جنودها الشهداء في الجنوب تقول نحن
ننتظر انتهاء التحقيق من الاجهزه
اللبنانيه واعتقد ان هذا ما يجري ولكن اخذ
الامور قبل انتهاء التحقيقات الى اتهامات
سياسيه والى غيرها انا طب قولي لن اسال
سؤال عندما تخرج الاجهزه الامنيه
اللبنانيه وكلنا نعلم ان الاجهزه الامنيه
اللبنانيه حاليا هي موضوع ثقه للجميع
الاطراف اذا خرجت به تحقيق وخرجت النتائج
مغايره للالتهامات التي تطلق حاليا لماذا
لا ننتظر انتهاء التحقيقات الامنيه في في
هذا الملف همم الحادث حصل خارج نطاق خارج
نطاق صلاحيات اليونيفيل هذا بدايتها اي ان
خروج هذه الاله شكل قد يكون شكل استفزاز
الماء او قد يكون شكل قد يكون نتيجه لخطا
لخطا همم جغرافي ان انهم اضاعوا الطريق او
اي ذلك همم لننتظر ويا سيدي تحصل في ارقى
المجتمعات عندما يكون هناك مجموعات امنيه
مجموعات امنيه او عسكريه في مجتمع هي
بعيده عنه بالثقافه وبالتربيه تحصل هناك
هناك فئات وكلنا نعلم انه بين الامريكان
بين الجيش الامريكي الموجود في اوروبا في
المانيا وفي المانيا وفي ايطاليا
والمجتمعات الالمانيه والايطاليه وهو جيش
جيش موافق عليه دولتهم في ايام الحرب
البارده كانت تحصل هناك قضايا مثل ذلك
وكلنا ان برلين عندما كانت مقسومه برلين
كان هناك احداث كثيره تحصل بين الجيش
الامريكي
والمدنيين الالمانيين ولكن كانت تنتهي هذه
المواضيع والاستفزازات عند لانه كان هناك
تحقيق شفاف يصدر عن اجهزه محايده نحن ندعو
الى انتظار التحقيقات اوليه وكما قلت لك
حاليا الان جميع الاطراف اللبنانيه لديها
ثقه بالاجهزه الامنيه وبالجيش اللبناني
والمخابرات الجيش اللبناني الذي له وحده
الحق في التحقيق بمساعده اليونيفيد لننتظر
هذا الموضوع هذا
اخذ الامور الى الفتنه والى التحريض قبل
لماذا تاخذون الامور الى الفتنه والتحقيق
يعني وتحديد همم حتى من قام بهذا العمليه
وبالتالي لماذا لا تنتظرون قد يكون عمل
استفزازي من قوات اليونيفير كما يقول
السيد مالك
نحن لا نستقبل
ومستقبل لبنان الى الخطر لا يمكن فصل هذا
الموضوع عن مسار طويل عريض وعن دب المشكله
بانه هنالك جهه في لبنان لا تريد بان يكون
للدوله اللبنانيه القدره والقوه على بسط
سلطتها على كافه الاراضي وما زال هناك بعض
التبريرات التي
تعطي
على من اقدم على هذه الخطوه تمريرات صراحه
بعيده كل البعد عن الواقع لا اعتقد بانه
ان اضل السائق الطريق
يكون العقاب من خلال قتله وبالتالي نحن
نتكلم اليوم عن مجموعه من الجنود
تركوا بلادهم واتوا الى لبنان قياضمنوا
استقراره
الحدود بين لبنان والعدو الاسرائيلي لذلك
في مصلحه الدوله ولا تصب في مصلحه لبنان
ومؤسساته الداخليه وعلى علاقته مع الخارج
نحن اليوم لا يجب التوقف فقط عند هذه
الحادثه بل يجب الذهاب نحو العديد من
الحوادث التي حصلت في الجنوب منذ مقتل
سامر حتى اليوم وقد يكون اخرها مقتل لقمان
سليم منذ من سنتين وبالتالي الحوادث
المتكرره التي تحصل في الجنوب تؤكد بان
هذه المناطق التي هي خاضعه لنفوس حزب الله
ما زالت عصيه على الدوله اللبنانيه وما
زالت الحوادث التي ستحصل هنا تؤدي الى ضرب
هيبه الدوله والى ضرب اا سياده الدوله
اللبنانيه والى ضرب مؤسسات الدوله
اللبنانيه ومن هنا على كافه الحارسين
الذين يريدون بناء الدوله حقيقيه وجمهوريه
فعاليه بان يطرح السؤال واكثر من السؤال
بان يبادرا نعم ضمن المؤسسات الدستوريه
الى الطلب الى توقف هذه المواضيع وان تكون
وحده القوى والسلطه الشرعيه السلطه سيد
جاده من القيادي في حزب القوات اللبنانيه
شكرا جزيلا لك وكذلك الشكر موصول لملكنادر
الكاتب الصحفي كنتما معي من بيروت
[موسيقى]
بانوراما مستمره وفي بعض الفاصل
بعد عرضها للمسلسل الوثائقي هاري وميجانا
هل يتدارك اعضاء الاسره المالكه
البريطانيه الموقف الخلافي المتكرر عبر
التاريخ ام تعمقهم منصه الترفيه العملاقه
نتفليكس لتثبت انها الاقوى اثرا من المسرح
والصحافه مقارنه بالماضي
[موسيقى]